[Musique]
1715 à partir de 1715 la compagnie
orientale des Indes impose au colon de
cultiver du café pour
l'exportation c'est la première culture
clé de l'histoire de la Réunion poussé
par la popularité croissante de cet or
noir en Europe et la découverte de
caféer sauvages dans l'île 1711 la
compagnie décide d'introduire des plants
de l'espèce
MOCA les paysages se transformment et
les caféères comme celle de Maison rouge
à Saint-Louis se multiplie dans les
années
1750 le besoin de main d'œuvre pour ce
travail complexe de la plantation au
séchage sur les argamases accélère
l'introduction d'esclav et certains
colons font
fortune la concurrence internationale
les maladies et les cyclones entîn le
déclin de cette culture à partir des
années
1780 la culture du café ne disparaît pas
mais son exportation cesse après la
Seconde Guerre
mondiale riche de cet héritage la
Réunion dispose aujourd'hui de l'un des
meilleurs cafés du monde Le Bourbon
Pointu résultat d'une mutation de caféer
d'Arabie il se caractérise par des
arômes délicats et des saveurs fruitées
il est cultivé par une poignée de
producteur
réunionné 1715 début de la culture du
[Musique]
café